(man) The sharks are back,
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
Last year,
we did $1.25 million.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money...
How is it worth
a million dollars?
(both, high-pitched voice)
because it's awesome!
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
The problem with Robert's offer is...
there's no problem with Robert's offer.
You get nothing.
Have you even made an offer?
I'm trying to,
but you keep interrupting me.
But first the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
You're going up against
the big boys now
with our dollars.
It's sink...
you're gonna get crushed,
my friend. Crushed.
Or swim.
Here's what I'm going
to offer you.
What? You're kidding.
Sorry, can I--
You're screwing up, Rusty.
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Lori Greiner,
the queen of qvc,
holds over a hundred patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing over
a half a billion dollars
in retail sales.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
who grew his homemade
clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
♪♪
First into the tank
are Jayson Sandberg
and Taylor Gwiazdon,
who believe they've made
a common product
that everybody has
even better.
Hi, my name
is Jayson Sandberg.
And my name is
Taylor Gwiazdon.
We are the proud owners
of liddup corporation,
and we're seeking $100,000
for a 10% equity stake
in our company.
We are very excited
to be here
and to finally introduce
the liddup cooler.
(imitates drumroll)
(both) ♪ Ahh ♪
ahh!
(Lori and Robert laugh)
The liddup cooler is
the first and only cooler
with built-in
L.E.D. lighting.
These bad boys
give you the ability
to find what
you're looking for.
It's as simple as that.
This is not rocket science.
This is exactly how
I came up with the idea.
I was camping
with my family.
I was thirsty,
about four hot dogs deep,
wanting an ice-cold beer.
I went to
my cold, dark cooler.
I began sloshing around,
frozen-handed,
trying to find
what I was looking for.
I found a can. I popped
it open... and it was a soda.
Not what I was looking for.
Oh, no!
(Kevin) Horrible!
(Lori and Robert laugh)
I began my search for a cooler
with lights in it,
and it did not take long
to realize there were none--
None in existence.
So I built my own.
We have working prototypes
and we're ready
to introduce our technology
to a world that needs to see
our product.
So...
who's ready to strike a deal,
raise a toast,
and get liddup?
(both, high-pitched voice)
because it's awesome!
(laughs)
So why would we ever
get in business
with rude and selfish
individuals like you?
I'm talking about two guys who
just opened a cooler of beer...
beer and didn't share
anything with anybody.
And didn't offer it to anybody.
Oh, shoot!
Yes. Sorry about that.
(Daymond) How about that?
That is very rude.
(Lori and Robert laugh)
(Taylor) Who would like one?
Why, I would.
(Robert) Sure. I'll have one.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah, bro. Thanks.
Salud to the shark tank.
(clinking)
Cheers, Kevin.
We already got something
out of the deal.
Whoo!
Now, Taylor and Jayson,
when I heard Daymond
call you greedy,
I thought
he was talking about
the valuation
you put on your business.
Oh, that's next.
Because you've asked me
for $100,000 for 10%,
implying that this is worth
a million dollars.
Defend yourselves
before I drink your beers.
So we have designed
and developed
a revolutionary product
for a very large, $500-Million
gross sales industry.
We feel that our product's worth
a million dollars
and we're looking for
a strong strategic partner
to help us take it to market.
But why do you feel
it's worth a million dollars?
(Daymond)
Those words all just meant
that
"I don't have any sales."
Correct?
Correct.
(Robert) So, Jayson, you never
answered the question.
How is it worth
a million dollars?
We had to start somewhere,
so that's where we started at.
(sharks laugh)
Awesome! Awesome!
(Taylor) Yeah.
You know, most honest--
Not good,
but most honest answer ever.
Well, we appreciate that.
We're honest guys, so...
(sharks laugh)
Have you shown it to any buyers
in the large box stores
that sell all of the coolers?
Uh, we have not shown it
to any retailers yet,
uh, and that's on purpose.
We've been waiting to develop
our intellectual property
to help secure our technology
and to protect us.
What is the intellectual
property in this? Like...
(laughs)
Do you have a patent
or is one pending?
We actually have
three issued patents.
Our patents cover the interior,
uh, L.E.D. Lighting.
And no one can put an L.E.D.
Anywhere inside a cooler
except you two dudes?
Correct.
I have some potentially bad news
for you.
I think there's only a couple
of people that make coolers,
and they own most of the market.
Am I right?
Yes.
Yes, 100% correct.
There's three manufacturers,
right?
(mouths word)
And therein lies your problem,
because it's a zero-sum game.
Either you're gonna get them
to play ball with you
and light it up with you,
or it's almost gonna be
impossible to get shelf space
unless you spend
an obscene amount of money.
Have you approached them?
Uh, that's the reason
why we're here,
is we have not because--
Because we were securing
our intellectual property
and protecting ourselves.
You agree the right strategy is
not to build your own coolers?
It's to go to one of
the three guys,
with a patent that's protected,
and create a license opportunity
where you get paid--
a few dollars if you're lucky,
a few cents if you're not--
for every single cooler
with lights.
Wouldn't that be wonderful?
Yes, sir.
Now that is interesting.
But technically,
why do you need us then?
Because all roads lead to
Mr. Wonderful
when it comes to
negotiating a license deal.
(both laugh)
We know that.
(all laugh)
Taylor and Jayson,
you're asking $100,000 for 10%--
It means a million dollars.
And I, you know,
when I see numbers like that,
you know what I'm gonna say.
I know a guy in the Hood
that will follow you around...
with a flashlight.
With a flashlight
and show you your beer
for the rest of your life
for a million dollars.
(Lori laughs)
I'm out.
Okay.
Daymond's got
half the Hood employed now.
(all laugh)
I think it's interesting.
I'm not sure how big a need
there is for it.
Anybody could really buy
a tap light
and put it in their cooler.
Correct.
That's correct.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
(Robert) So, guys,
here's the good news.
One of my best Friends is one of
the largest makers of tents
and accessories for them.
So he knows that market
inside out,
and we've done
a bunch of deals together.
So I can set up a meeting
with the largest manufacturer
of coolers in the world
very easily.
I'll give you the $100,000...
for 25% of the company,
and we'll see what happens
at the meeting.
I'll tell you what, guys.
I love the beer. Thank you.
I'm out. Say "Yes" Before
he changes his mind.
All right, the problem
with Robert's offer is...
there's no problem
with Robert's offer.
There's only one potential
there--his friend.
It won't work
unless you have two bids.
Because what you want to create
is the potential of this market
in their minds.
If there are two bidders,
the advance is huge.
If there's one,
you get nothing.
This is what uncle Kevin knows,
and this is where he brings
the big value.
Only an idiot would
walk into a meeting
and give the impression
that there isn't other players
in the market.
The way you get maximum value
is by creating a position
with the first guy
so that they feel
a certain amount of pressure
so you don't
walk across the street.
Robert's wrong because you are
working an oligopoly.
There are 3 companies
that own over 80% share.
Have you even made an offer?
I'm trying to,
but you keep interrupting me.
I'm gonna make it easy. I'm not
gonna ask for any equity at all.
I'll give you the $100,000
for one-Third, 33%,
of whatever we get to license it
from a cooler manufacturer,
whichever one it is.
But I'm there by your side
negotiating it,
hockey sticking it,
soccer balling it,
race driving it
along with you.
Guys, he's just blowing smoke.
We're all good at negotiating
up here.
I like to depend on people
who've been in the business.
Kevin negotiates
from a point of aggression.
I'm happy to walk in
with my friend,
who's been doing business
with these guys for 20 years.
And they'll be honest with you
and tell you whether
there's a deal here or not.
Can we consult
for just a minute?
Absolutely.
Hey, guys, I'll make it
really easy.
If that offer's attractive
for you, go for it.
I'm out.
(Daymond) whoa!
You got one offer left
on the table.
Let's do business, Kevin.
(claps hands)
(chuckles)
I'm very excited, gentlemen.
I'm gonna drink a beer
in your honor.
Kevin, you just got lit up
by liddup.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
It's great.
Let's get started.
It's very interesting.
(high-Pitched voice)
what?
(Robert)
Hey, I wasn't listening.
Did you take
their royalties forever
and their firstborn?
Uh, left the firstborn out.
(laughs)
gosh! I can't believe it.
All this time--
We got a deal with Kevin.
That's who we wanted
to get a deal with.
All this time,
all this hard work...
ohh. It feels great.
It feels absolutely awesome.
We can't wait
to light up the world.
♪♪
Next up is Dave Alwan,
who hopes to whet
the sharks' appetites
with quality meats.
Hi. I'm Dave Alwan
of Echo Valley meats
from Peoria, Illinois,
the heart of the midwest.
I am seeking $300,000
for 20% equity.
Echo valley meats makes
the best meat you'll ever eat.
We specialize
in that old-fashioned
Butcher shop quality
and deliver
the most delicious meats
from the farm
to tables nationwide.
This business is in my blood.
I'm third generation
in the meat business,
a cattleman and a farmer.
My motto is simple--
Know the meat business
from conception to consumption,
and I know this business
better than anyone.
I'd love for your family,
friends, and clients
to say "Wow!" When they receive
a gift from ECHO valley meats.
I assure that partnering
with one of you
for creative vision,
connections, and knowledge
of the e-Commerce
will help take Echo valley meats
to the next level of success.
You're the sharks,
and now it's time
for a feeding frenzy.
(Lori and Robert laugh)
Ladies first.
(Robert) Oh, wow.
(Lori) Thank you. Wow.
Robert.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
I love cold cuts.
(Mark) Thank you, sir.
(Dave) Now I can
assure you...
(Robert) Whoa.
Whoa.
Making money
never tasted so good.
Wow. David, can you tell us
what we were eating? What--
Sure. Uh, the one
on your plate, Robert,
to the far--
Your left hand there,
that would be
a beef tenderloin.
That would be--
Very good.
Good.
Um, the other one would be
our hickory smoked
beef brisket,
which we slow-roast for
about 15 to 16 hours ourselves.
That was outstanding.
Um, the other one
is our ham,
which is a-a-again,
a natural juice ham,
so there's no water added
to it.
And what was this?
That is our summer sausage.
That is an award-winning
summer sausage as well.
Fantastic.
Tell us about
the--the business side of it.
Uh, last year,
we did $1.25 million...
(Kevin and Lori) Whoa.
Between retail, catering,
and our mail order.
So when you say retail,
what does that mean?
I have a retail in Peoria.
You have a retail store?
Yes, in Peoria.
Oh. Okay.
How do customers find you?
Right now, it's literally,
uh, word of mouth.
I have been developing this
for the past ten years,
literally guerilla marketing.
I get in my car and take samples
to local businesses
around Peoria--
$25 gift boxes,
$50 gift boxes--
and drop 'em off to corporations
and say, "This is what we do."
Dave, how does
the price point compare
to the other competitors,
and the quality?
42% cheaper than pretty much
anybody in the industry.
I have stuck to the basics,
believe in the best product.
I knew it was gonna take me
a lot longer
to get to where I wanted to go,
but I've stuck to my roots.
So if you're offering, uh,
the same quality
or a better quality Product
for cheaper,
what are you margins
on your products?
Um,
on the mail-Order business,
at the end of the day
on any of these items,
we net about 26% to 28%
across the board.
This particular ham here,
which is about an 8- To
10-Pound spiral-Sliced ham,
would retail in the catalog
for $49.
That ham cost me between
$16 and $18 before packaging.
Are you trying to go
into other retail outlets?
No, I'd like to go into
more mail order than retail.
You wanna go straight direct.
That's right.
What did you make
on that $1.25 million in Sales?
Uh, we only netted
about $20,000.
Is that after
you paid yourself something?
Yes.
David, on $1.25 million in
sales, you basically broke even.
That's what happened.
That's correct.
So--
(Robert) Why, David?
I paid for everything
as I went.
Um, I have--all of my equipment
is paid for in full.
Um, my smokehouse Alone
would cost
a quarter-Million dollars
to pay for,
my sausage Stuffer's $150,000,
if you were gonna
buy this stuff brand-new.
Everything's paid for
in full.
But, Dave, if I take out
the one-time cost
of the equipment...
Let's say you did
$1.2 million next year
and got rid
of those one-Time costs.
How much money
would you have made?
Um...
probably closer to $50,000.
(Robert) Why is the profit
so low?
You know, when you're making
that little bit of money,
one little thing goes wrong,
and...
from this point forward,
once we go over
the $3-Million mark,
everything becomes profit.
Our overhead doesn't change
one bit. Um...
so you have a cost structure
that you've gotta do a certain
amount just to break even.
That's right. 1.2
is basically our break-Even,
and that's where we're at
right now.
So I give you the $300,000.
What do you spend it on?
Um, I would think
purely marketing
and bringing in product
inventory before the season.
But what type of marketing?
There's...
uh, national e-commerce.
I think that's where the growth
is, really, is e-commerce.
The problem with that,
David, is,
do you know what it cost you
to acquire a new customer?
Um, not really,
to be honest with you.
We've been developing this,
recreating the Web site,
just really fine-Tuning
last multiple years
to get to where we're at now.
But you wanna take my $300,000
to experiment
to find those answers.
I don't know what
it's gonna cost
to get a customer that comes
back every holiday to buy a ham.
You don't, either.
You're gonna go find out.
You're gonna spend
my $300,000 doing it.
Maybe you'll be successful,
maybe you won't be
because--
I know a--I know a customer
that ordered $1,400
only ordered $900 last year.
So I-I feel
in the past several years
I have not lost any business.
Each customer has came back
and continued to grow with us.
Dave, I don't--I don't think
that there's any doubt
This is a fantastic product.
The meat was great.
But here is my challenge--
I didn't know about you
until you walked out here,
I buy stuff like this
all the time...
Sure.
As corporate gifts
for our corporate customers.
But Kevin's right.
It's very, very expensive
to find those people.
These people mail me,
they e-mail me,
they blast me
all kinds of stuff.
And I'm--I'm struggling
with the $300,000.
Like, I-I know that's
a lot of money.
But I don't know. I think
it's gonna cost a lot more.
(Daymond) Yeah, I mean, my--
My challenge is the same thing.
You're going up against
the big boys now
with our dollars.
One point that you said to me
that would help you
that was attractive was
yours is a $49 ham.
And I think the other hams
out there are like $69, $79.
And that's
at a smaller weight also.
So they're
significantly higher...
uh-huh.
With not as much product also.
I think that's
a real distinct advantage,
'cause the other stuff--
You're right, Lori--
Is way more money.
(Kevin) I don't know if it's--
It's actually--Yeah,
it's not an advantage at all
because you're not making money.
They're--they're selling
their product at a higher price
because, obviously,
they have to.
(Lori) They're making more.
Yeah.
But again, I've only targeted
60 miles around Peoria.
(Kevin) No, but I think
what we'll find out, Dave,
is the reason
they're $79 on your $49 ham
is that their cost of customer
acquisition is the difference.
And you'd find that out. You're
not gonna be any different.
It's gonna cost money,
maybe $20 more per order.
If we would get to
a $5-Million point
on our mail-Order business
alone and net 28%,
for $300,000, you would have
100% return on Investment back
within basically--
Yeah, but that's--That's--
(Robert) Yeah, but you're not--
You're not telling us--
That--That's a long road
from here to there.
Dave, here's where you
screwed up, all right?
You know the meat business.
You make a great product.
You proved it.
But what you've told us is,
your retail business
is your retail business.
You see the upside,
because the margins are greater,
in the direct mail business,
particularly through e-commerce.
The one thing you didn't do
was come prepared
to explain to us why.
You're coming in unprepared.
That doesn't cut it.
I'm out.
Okay.
(Robert)
You're making the assumption
people are gonna buy
your product and stay with you,
but you're not answering
the question--
How much it's gonna cost
to find that customer.
Yeah.
I think you came up
with $300,000.
I asked you, how are you gonna
specifically spend that,
and you say marketing,
national marketing.
And maybe it's sending out
samples like I did, you know,
in my car--
Oh, whoa, Dave.
You never wanna talk
about "Maybe."
Yeah.
You know,
I-I grew up on a farm.
Right, you know, a farmer
doesn't go out in the field
and throw a bunch of seeds out
and says,
"Gee, I hope there's corn
next year."
(chuckles)
Yeah. True.
That's what you're doing.
True.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Okay.
But I will take more sausage.
(Lori and Robert laugh)
there's plenty of that.
Can't call
your business plan bad
because there isn't one.
It's kind of an interesting
problem you have here, Dave.
The product is
absolutely spectacular.
Thank you.
And the strategy to get it
into the market isn't there,
at least,
in terms of e-commerce.
I don't see the opportunity
'cause you didn't present it
to me. I'm out.
Okay.
Daymond or Lori?
You probably can't tell it,
but I-I generally try not
to eat red meat. I eat fish.
Um, I'm trying not to go
in that area of business.
Um, you know, my kids are vegans
and things of that nature.
So from just
that standpoint alone,
I'm out.
And, Lori?
I really like you...
thank you.
And I think the product
is amazing.
I have a lot of experience
with catalog sales.
And it is hard
to get your name known,
and you do have
a lot of competition.
I think that you'll make it,
slowly.
But I like to get things
out there really quickly
to get my return
on my investment,
and I don't see that
happening here.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Good luck, David.
Well, thank you, guys.
Have a great day.
(Mark) Thank you.
(Lori) Good luck.
You know, it's amazing.
If he wasn't
as nice as he was...
think about it.
He came out here with no plan.
(Daymond and Lori laugh)
(Robert) We've--We've shredded
people with that same thing,
But the guy was
just a nice guy.
Yeah, and he gave us--
And he fed you.
He gave us
a good piece of steak.
You know, sometimes it's good
to feed the sharks. (chuckles)
(Daymond) Yeah.
♪♪
My name is Colin Grussing.
I'm from New Orleans, Louisiana.
♪♪
Living in New Orleans is great.
Everywhere you look,
there's people in costumes,
street performers.
Everyone's just going crazy.
(cheering)
Seeing that dynamic
in New Orleans
really helped inspire
my product.
(laughs)
I studied mechanical engineering
at Yale.
I've never really thought
of myself as a creative person,
but when it does come
to building things,
I do often find creative ways
to solve problems.
New order's in.
All right!
What?
My business doesn't just
sell a product.
It's really more of a lifestyle.
It'll take any experience
and make it incredible.
Try it?
I think it can be
the next social phenomenon.
And there's something a little
bit mysterious about it.
I really need an investment
from the sharks
to really
get the brand out there
and make it a household name.
♪♪
Hi, my name is Colin Grussing,
and my business is rootsuit.
I'm here seeking
a $100,000 investment
for 15% of my company.
I could describe the product
to you,
but I think it's probably better
to just show you.
(blows whistle)
♪♪
(sharks laughing)
Oh, my lord.
(Lori) Oh, my god!
Aah!
(Mark) what up, baby?
So... This is a rootsuit.
Wearing a rootsuit
is an incredible experience
that you can't get
in any other way.
It lets you stand out
in a crowd
and gives you
this unique charisma.
You are compelled to do things
you otherwise wouldn't.
Wear rootsuit to a concert,
you'll probably get pulled
on stage.
Wear a rootsuit to the game,
I bet you get on the jumbotron.
Wear rootsuit to the bank,
you probably get 7 to 10.
Yes.
(laughs) Yes.
(laughs)
That's True.
So back to our business.
(sharks laugh)
aah!
We started selling
rootsuits in 2008,
and as soon
as we gave it a name,
it blew up.
I know we're poised
for huge growth.
So who wants to join me
in the rootsuit phenomenon?
Can you see easily
through it?
You can see pretty well.
Like any costume
that covers your face,
there is limited visibility.
Tell us about sales.
Are you making any money?
Oh, yeah. Absolutely.
Okay, so last year,
what did you sell?
Last year we sold
a little under 10,000.
Dollars?
No, units.
Units.
How many dollars is that?
So that's, uh,
$525,000.
What?
(Kevin) Ooh.
Make it any money on that?
Yeah, yeah, last year was
$140,000 in profit.
Wow.
Tell us about
your sales model.
How do you sell it?
Where do you sell it?
What are your markets?
It's all e-Commerce.
Seems like
the natural place for it.
No retailers?
No retailers.
That's a big part of
the reason why I'm here.
(Robert) are you
the only guy?
'cause I'm pretty sure my son,
who's 18,
all his buddies wear
suits like this,
and they go to nightclubs
and parties.
A-absolutely. Absolutely.
So you--You have
seen it before?
That's my question.
Would I have seen yours
or is there a bunch of people
making these?
So were the first.
We started in 2008.
We totally originated--
Opened up This product space.
We had quick
and profound success,
and of course some people
have come in--
So you have competition?
We have competition,
absolutely.
So you're the--
You're the main brand.
We are the--
You were the first guy.
We were the first guys.
Is there any brand recognition
on the suit itself?
Does it say "rootsuit"
on it anywhere,
like on the foot
or anything like that?
Just so somebody can say, "Hey,
look. This is where I got it"?
That's probably a good idea.
This is one thing
that I'd actually like
to investigate a little more.
(Robert) This is super hot
right now.
You go snowboarding,
the kids are wearing this
on the ski hills.
It's super, super--
Oh, there you go--Super hot.
But here's the problem--
Maybe you created the market,
but there's no way to know
This is your product.
I think it's a--It's a big
challenge ahead of you.
I'm out.
Oh. I'm sorry
to hear that.
I do have--I have a--
I have a--
Definitely an answer
for that.
Um--
Go ahead. You got
four other sharks.
Well, Colin...
okay. Okay.
I'll--I'll tell you, too.
I think they're very cool.
I really like them.
But I do think you have
a competition problem.
I-I can't see you
protecting this in any way
and I can see a lot of other
people making it.
And so for that reason,
I'm out.
Let me speak to that...
(laughs) Before--Before--
Before you all think that
that's a huge problem.
I mean, lots--Lots of
businesses have competition.
And the way that they do it--
I'm talking to you now--
Um, is through branding...
Yeah.
You know? I mean,
how many people came in after
you started what you started
and make--Make
very similar things,
but people kept buying yours
because you were able
to brand it.
Correct.
(Kevin)
I like to put money into things
that get really big
so I get much richer.
Yeah.
That's sort of my strategy.
I-I don't know how this is
going to turn into
a $50-Million
squeeze-a-guy-in-a-suit
business.
For me as an investment,
it ain't there. I'm out.
You are making money.
We're making
a lot of money.
But the only way that it's
of value to me is
to own a good portion
of the company, number one.
Number two, we know
it can go to retail.
I'm gonna have to give you
an offer
that's gonna be
a very sharky offer.
I'll give you, uh,
the $100,000 for 50%.
(chuckles)
okay. I-I really appreciate
the offer.
That--I'm doing numbers
in my head.
Is there a contingency
on that?
Contingency is that
we have to get it into retail.
Get it into retail.
I love--
(Robert) wow.
'cause then I know my work
starts at that point.
Well, you got an offer.
I love--Let me say,
I love that contingency
and I would--
there's no one in the world
I would rather do that with
than you. (chuckles)
Um...
that's great. Um...
You may want to hear
from Mr. Cuban first.
He's been known to do
really crazy things.
I want to hear what you say
to his offer first.
Okay. Well, I'm... sorry.
Can I...
I got really excited.
I'd like to take a second
to think about this.
(mark laughs)
You don't seem really excited.
Yeah, he does.
He's like... (flat voice)
"Yeah, ah, that's great."
(Robert) So, Colin,
it's an interesting position.
Three sharks are out.
One has made an offer.
Which is--
The last one is saying
"I'm not telling you
want I'm gonna do
until you tell me what
the other guy's doing."
I think...
what do you do?
That what I--the people
I would love
to work with the most
would be you two.
I think you should throw in
$100,000, too.
(Daymond) but I'm not gonna work
with him.
(laughs) And own 100%
of the company?
No, no, no. Let's keep it--
Let's keep it at 50%.
(sharks laugh)
I-I'm--I'm not
gonna work with mark.
I really--
Okay.
You should
maybe entertain mark,
because I'm on the fence.
I may actually
take that offer back.
(Kevin) Often this happens.
A dog has a bone in its jaws.
It gets to a bridge.
(speaks indistinctly)
It looks down. It sees
the reflection of another bone.
Opens its mouth
to get that one,
and "Oh, no.
The first bone's gone!"
(mark laughs)
I mean, there is--
There is--
I think you've got a bone
in your mouth right now...
okay.
And you don't want
to get boned,
so you better think
a little bit about this.
♪♪
Three sharks are out.
Daymond has made an offer
of $100,000
for 50% of the company,
but Colin may have
jeopardized the deal
by waiting for Mark.
Um, do you--
(Lori) This is
your defining moment.
You know, I've said this
to people before,
and I've watched it happen
so many times--
Lori, stop. Colin,
I-I like you. I'm out.
Oh.
(Mark) what?
(Kevin) wow.
I was on the fence,
but I'm out.
What happened there,
Daymond?
He's taking too long.
I know that I would've had to
put in a large amount of work.
I don't like
an indecisive person.
Colin,
bone-In-mouth disease.
(mark laughs)
You--You were exactly right.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, it's a shame.
And now there's one.
(Mark) Look...
hi, man.
I think you're smart.
I love the business.
You're gonna keep on growing.
You're doing
all the right things.
You're gonna make
a boatload of money off of this.
You want to do some of that?
Bu the issue is,
you'd be an idiot
to take a partner,
because you're good,
right?
There's just some businesses
that are better off
being owned
by the entrepreneur
and just going out there
and kicking ass,
and that's you.
What are you saying, mark?
You in, you out?
I'm out.
But I'm rooting for you...
well--
because you're gonna be great.
Well, thank you so much
for your time.
I really appreciate
the advice and everything.
I think you're gonna do Well.
Yeah, yeah, I do, too.
You've already done well.
You'll continue to grow.
Okay, thanks so much.
(Lori) Good luck.
He's like a superhero
when he puts that suit on.
(Lori laughs)
(Kevin) Maybe there's
a lesson in that.
Maybe you come in here--
You gotta be fast
and you'll be made an offer.
Gotta be decisive.
No, I think the lesson is,
put a bone in Kevin's mouth
and see where he drops it.
(laughs) I don't have
bone-In-mouth disease.
(laughs)
♪♪
Earlier this season,
we watched Lucinda Lent
and Juliet Boydstun
make a deal
with Barbara Corcoran
for their children's party spot
the coop.
We are thrilled to be
in business with you, Barbara.
Let's see
what they're up to now.
(Juliet) Business is booming
since we've been on
"Shark tank."
It's amazing.
We're so excited.
I'm sorry. We're all sold out
that weekend.
Last year our sales
were around $350,000.
This year, we're on track
to be at a million dollars.
(Lucinda, australian accent)
We have been inundated
with franchise requests.
We're in talks right now
to open a location in miami
and one in Washington, D.C.
And we have plans to expand
in Los Angeles next year.
(both) Hi, Barbara.
I've been expecting your call.
Nice to see both of you.
Barbara has been amazing.
I never doubted for a minute
that you would succeed.
But I was so worried
that your business
would be confined
by those walls.
With Barbara's help,
we figured out a way
to expand and get our parties
outside of the coop.
♪♪
We've just launched
the coop parties 2 go,
where we bring a cool
coop party to your house.
(children) Happy birthday!
And we've also created
the coop crate
so we can pack up
all the cool coop stuff
and ship it to you
anywhere in the country.
(Lucinda and Juliet)
the party's here!
We have so many moms
that come to us who say,
"I've got this great idea,"
and then they'll say,
"because we saw you
on 'shark tank,'
"We know that it's possible.
"you can be a mom,
you can have kids,
and you can live your dream."
♪♪
Next into the tank
is Rusty Allen,
who feels he's added
function and design
to an everyday product.
♪♪
Hi, sharks.
My name is Rusty Allen.
I'm an industrial design
entrepreneur
and the founder
of gobieh2o.
I'm asking for
a $300,000 investment
for 10% of my company.
Four years ago,
when the recession hit
I realized I was spending
more money
on single-use water bottles
per gallon
than I was on the gas that
I was putting into my car.
(thuds)
And that pissed me off.
And that's when I decided
to develop gobie.
Gobie is the world's
most advanced filtered
water bottle on the market.
Our flex flow technology
allows you to have
the durability of a hard-shell
with the accessibility
of a soft-shell.
What that allows you to do
is have clean,
purified water instantly.
One thing that I realized
after developing this product
was we could filter out
way more than just tap water,
and I'd love to show you
what I mean by that.
With our upgraded filter,
we have the ability
to filter out
99.99% of all contaminants
found in water.
For the purpose
of this demo,
I'm just gonna take ordinary
dirt and throw it in there.
This is
really fine potting soil.
Shake it up.
This is disgusting,
dirty, dirty water
that no one
would ever want to drink.
Now with this upgraded filter,
it allows the ability
to filter out clean,
purified water instantly,
anywhere you go.
Mm.
Oh.
So I would love to
show you guys this product
in person.
Ladies first.
Thank you.
You bet.
There you go.
Thanks, Rusty.
You bet.
Here you go.
Thank you, Rusty.
Which one of you sharks
wants to invest in clean,
purified gobie success?
Are you looking to sell this,
Rusty,
as a mainstream product
in America
to compete with all the other
water containers
or are you trying to go
into the specialty niche
of providing purified water
in countries
where it's not available?
Right now, the special filter
is a prototype.
And that's a great thing,
and that was--
That shows the power
of our technology.
But my main Focus right now
is to compete with single-Use
water bottles here in America.
But don't you think,
here in America,
people are pretty comfortable
filling up
their existing bottles today
with water out of the tap?
They don't need
the extra cost of a filter.
Kevin's right, shockingly.
Not only are we accepting
tap water
or other forms of water
outside of the bottle,
but there's also other filters
that filter good enough.
(Robert) Yeah, Rusty.
I mean, my kids have
a water bottle,
and it has a filter
on the inside of it.
And they've had that
for, my gosh, three years.
But probably not the same
kind of filter this is.
No, it is.
The only difference I see
in yours
is that you have this soft,
compressible area
and a Harder shell--
The two combined together.
I haven't seen that, but...
okay.
I have seen
multiple products
where there is a filter
just like yours
that takes out 99.9%
of the contaminants...
okay.
That you can either put into
different water bottles...
Yeah.
Or that already come
built inside.
Right, well, I'll--
I'll show you--
the--I'll show you
the beauty of that technology--
Flex flow technology.
What it allows us to do...
And most--Most squeeze bottles,
they won't last the life
of the filter
because they're not
very durable,
they scratch up.
They end up not holding
a Seal really Well
because it's
soft materials, right?
Well,
the hard-Shell bottles
are really good,
but if you have a filter
in it,
you have to suck
the water through.
Which really limits what kind
of filter you can put in there.
So the ability to have
a hard-shell
combined with a soft-Shell
is the best of both worlds.
(Robert)
No, but, Rusty, hang on.
You're saying
all the other products,
which do the same thing,
can't filter to a level
that you can?
Yours is so good
that you can filter dirt.
Nobody else can do that?
In the way that we do.
That's a different answer
to a different question.
Well, there--There are--
Okay.
We've tested our filter
in other water bottles,
and we've realized
that this technology--
The flex flow technology--
Builds up a ton
of pressure in here
and allows you to filter out
more than everybody else can.
(Daymond) I never thought
I would say it,
but this is an extremely sexy
water bottle,
you know,
to tell you the truth.
All right.
Thank you. I appreciate it.
How much
does this cost retail?
Retail is $30.
How much
are you making them for?
We're making them for $10
in the U.S. Right now.
We're made in san Diego.
That includes the first filter,
which is for tap water.
That filter lasts 3 months
or 100 gallons.
The consumer buys it
every quarter. Very simple.
Oh, so you have to keep on
re-Buying the filter?
Yeah. Yeah, that's repeat...
okay, let me ask
one more question.
Filter sales.
Did you license the filter
or is this 100% your design?
You did all the work
as an industrial engineer?
As far as the technology of it,
it's a carbon block.
It's--It's--It's free market,
uh, technology.
What were your sales?
Our sales to date,
only online,
have been 10,000 bottles
and 15,000 filters.
What's your total sales?
Revenue, what is that?
Total s--
Revenue is $285,000.
Over what period of time?
17 months.
Okay.
Just so you guys know,
as far as sales,
I've only been selling
the blue bottle.
We went to retail--
Who did you go to?
Bed Bath & Beyond,
Target, and jcpennys.
What happened?
So they came back
and they said,
"in order to get this in there,
we need more colors."
Wait. I have to stop you
for a minute,
because that doesn't
make sense to me.
If they thought that this was
so original and so unique
and something
that they really wanted,
they would've grabbed it,
they would've tested it.
So my feeling is
you didn't get into them
because there are already
so many others
out there like it,
and they probably have
a less-Expensive version.
I like that you are creative
and that you're trying
to do something
and be an entrepreneur.
But I think there's tons
of competition out there,
and for that reason, I'm out.
Okay. That's fine.
I have a different issue
with you, Rusty,
which we haven't
addressed yet.
Explain to me why
you're worth $3 million today
and how it's gonna be
worth more tomorrow.
Because unless we get
past that, Rusty,
I don't care what colors
the bottles are,
you're not getting
any of my money.
Well, first of all,
you guys know
every human being on the earth--
the richest man in Beverly hills
and the poorest man in Kenya--
Both drink water.
And besides--Besides
breathing oxygen--
That's just a horrible
sales pitch, Rusty.
Come on.
Listen, I'm just saying
how broad it is.
Let me get back to my--
It's an obvious broad market.
(Kevin) Okay, Rusty,
here's the bottom line--
What you should've said is
that you were gonna sell
$3-Million worth
of these bottles
in the next 12 months,
make $500,000 or $600,000
in profit.
I would've had
a debate with you.
We would've stayed engaged.
You never did that.
I'm out.
Rusty, Rusty, let me clarify
your problem for you, okay?
You've got
really cool-looking bottles.
But you're trying to be in
the water filtration business.
The part
that differentiates you,
that makes it
a really cool product,
you're not focusing on
at all.
If you just walked in
and said,
"you know what? We have
the coolest, hippest,
"best-looking bottles
on the planet.
"and by the way,
"if you have a user who has
a need for daily filtration,
we have a solution."
You're screwing up, Rusty.
I see what you're saying.
I was getting caught up
in all the other details.
But the end of the day,
we're able to filter out
more prod--
More, uh, contaminants
than anyone else
because of this.
Rusty, look, I'm--
I'm gonna make it simple.
I'm out, right?
You're selling the wrong thing.
Rusty, you seem like a nice guy,
but that was just
a really convoluted
presentation, my friend.
I mean, that was just
so bad.
I don't think you understand,
uh, the business that you're in.
You're gonna get crushed,
my friend.
Crushed.
I'm out.
I'm sitting here quietly
rooting for you,
but every one
of the other sharks
are bringing up
really, really valuable points.
What do you want
the money for?
We need the money
for inventory
and a little bit
of operating cost.
Like I said,
I'm working 24/7,
seven days a week.
Uh, Rusty, just because--
No, listen.
Rusty, just because
you work hard...
can I finish really quick?
Doesn't mean
you're gonna be successful.
I--No, listen.
I-I want to hear this.
I want to hear this, rob.
I will work Harder than Anyone
has ever worked for you.
I swear.
I've been dedicating
my entire life to this.
I have a pad next to my desk
that I sleep on
and wake up and work.
I do not stop working,
dude.
How much debt
is on the company?
None.
♪♪
You may want to take
a nice swig of the water,
'cause I got an offer
coming to you.
You're kidding.
♪♪
Four of the sharks
are out.
But Daymond is interested.
How much debt
is on the company?
None.
You may want to take
a nice swig of the water,
'cause I got an offer
coming to you.
You're kidding.
I'll give you $300,000
for 40%
with this contingency--
We have...
to get it into
a big-box retailer.
What do you think
about 20%?
I think that you're coming
in here for smart money, right?
Yep.
But I also believe $300,000
for 40%
is what this deal is worth.
I'll just sort of sum up
what the--the--what the, uh,
what I'm selling here.
No, you don't need to.
(Mark) No, no.
He's made you an offer.
(inhales and exhales)
I would ask you, uh, can I
call my business partner?
I have an advisor,
graduated from Cornell.
He's an amazing guy,
and he would give me
great advice on this.
Absolutely.
You want to call? Sure.
Yes.
Thank you, guys. I--no--No hard
feelings that you're out.
No big deal. I appreciate
your offer, Daymond.
Okay.
Thanks a lot.
Is he leaving?
(man) Hey, Rusty.
How's it going?
It's going great, man.
I was, uh, a little confusing,
I guess,
on the way
that I presented things.
Daymond, I'm shocked.
Daymond, that was
the most confusing presentation
we've seen in...
all the sharks are out
except, uh, Daymond.
Okay.
And he's offering 40 per--
$300,000 for 40%.
So basically,
he's valuing the company
at $700,000.
It's so not worth
3 million bucks.
Guys, stop talking me
out of this.
I'm gonna--I'm gonna ask
one more question,
and then if they, uh,
if they're good with it, good.
And, uh, we'll figure it out.
Sounds great. All right.
Good luck, bud.
All right.
There's so much competition,
Daymond.
Yes,
this is a challenge.
But these are
badass-looking bottles.
Okay, Rusty,
before you say anything,
let's just summarize
where we're at.
Okay.
There's only one shark left--
Daymond--
Who's interested in your deal.
He offered you $300,000,
not for 10%--
what you wanted.
It's $300,000 for 40%
with a contingency
that the retailers
you've been talking about
that are so excited
about your product
actually bring it in
and start selling it.
What are you going to do?
I would really, um...
like to see what you thought
about bringing
a couple of more sharks in--
Mark Cuban and Lori--
for the demo purposes
as well as the mavs
and the sports, uh,
licensing potential there.
Rusty, I'll tell you the truth,
to tell you the truth, though,
this is such a gamble
and a flier
that I would want
that big reward.
So I wouldn't want them
in the deal.
$300,000 for 40%.
And you guys are all
still out for sure, 100%?
He just said he didn't
want us in,
so it's his call.
Okay, so you guys--
You guys offers are still
completely off the table
after I left?
Unless you want
to give up more equity.
No. Absolutely. Daymond.
All right. Good.
You're the man.
Let's do this, man.
You guys are r--
Gonna regret this.
I guarantee you, dude.
Actually,
I forgot my bottle.
I'm speechless.
How surprised are you,
D.J.?
I am surprised. I didn't think
he was gonna take 40%.
I was waiting
for you to say no,
and then I could get back
into the royalty game with him.
Squeeze his head
like a teenage pimple.
(laughs)
I think Daymond gets it
and I think we're gonna kill it.
And I think all the sharks
are gonna regret
not being a part of it.